Austin Butler's first public appearance
since Lisa Marie Presley's death Austin
attended the Critics Choice Awards on
Sunday just days after the tragedy
[Applause]
you're looking for trouble
came to the right place
Austin earned the best actor nomination
for his role as Lisa Marie's father
Elvis in the 2022 biopic he didn't take
home the trophy but he did NAB one
several days earlier thank you for
opening your hearts your your memories
your home to me Lisa Marie Priscilla I
love you forever
Austin recently won that same award at
the Golden Globes the event that marked
Lisa Marie's last public outing what was
it like watching Austin on stage and
during this movie in the making of this
movie it was mind-blowing truly
mind-blowing I really didn't know what
what to do with myself after after I saw
it yeah I had to take like five days to
process it
because it was so incredible and soap
spot on
and so authentic
that yeah I I can't even describe
what it meant Abbott Elementary Cheryl
Lee Ralph spoke with ET on Sunday ahead
of the Critics Choice Awards where she
reflected on the loss of Lisa Marie
after seeing her at the Globes just days
ago sad to say I was so close to Lisa
Marie and now she's gone you know it
just proves life is short love the
people you love and love on them
Lisa Marie was rushed to the hospital on
January 12th after going into full
Cardiac Arrest at her Calabasas home
where shortly after she died at the time
a rep for the Presley family released a
statement to ET that their quote shocked
and devastated Austin also shared his
condolences telling E.T he was quote
completely shattered adding quote I'm
eternally grateful for the time I was
lucky enough to be near her bright light
and will forever cherish The Quiet
Moments we shared her warmth her love
and her authenticity will always be
remembered the Presleys who have now
welcomed me into their family in such a
beautiful way and I just feel so
endlessly grateful to them that they
provided this space for me to somehow
try to capture the essence of this man
that they that means so much to them